الصراع في السودان يقترب من اتمام شهره
الاول والاوضاع على الارض تبقى على صفيح
ساخن ميدانيا وقعت خسائر بشريه وايضا في
الممتلكات تحديدا بمنطقه بحري بعد مهاجمه
الجيش السوداني لاماكن تتمركز فيها قوات
الدعم السريع وفي وقت لاحق اعلنت قوات
الدعم السريع عبر صفحتها الرسميه اسقاط
طائره ثانيه تابعه للجيش في منطقه بحر
اضافه للسيطره على الجسر الحلفايه الرابط
بين بحري وام درمان سياسيا تسعى الوساطه
السعوديه الامريكيه لاحداث اتفاق بين
الجيش والدعم السريع للتوصل الى وقف دائما
لاطلاق النار طبعا الجيش السوداني تمسك
بخروج غير مشروط لقوات الدعم السريع من
العاصمه وتجميع القوات في معسكر واحد وهو
ما رفضه الدعم السريع وفي اخر احصاء لعدد
الضحايا كشفت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان عدد
القتلى جراء الاشتباكات في السودان تجاوز
600 قتيل واكثر من خمسه الاف جريح حتى
الان اليوم اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان في
بيان ان 27 مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او حتى
جزئي في عموم ارجاء السودان من اصل 88
مستشفى محذره من انهيار القطاع الصحي
الصراع في السودان وكما ذكرنا يوم امس ادى
لنزوح اكثر من 700 الف شخص داخل البلاد
وفرار 150 الف شخص لدول مجاوره بينما توقع
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه التابع للامم
المتحده ان يعاني ما يصل الى مليونين و500
الف سوداني من الجوع بالاشهر المقبله ما
يرفع عدد من يعانون من انعدام الامن
الغذائي الحاد هناك الى تسعه عشره مليون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الض غط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات